- Words of the world are
the life of the world.
That line was first
spoken by Wallace Stevens
in his poem, "An Ordinary
Evening in New Haven,"
not far from here, 70 years
ago, November 4th, 1949.
Beinecke Library has
the typescript sheets,
the original typescript
that Mr. Stevens read from
on that ordinary evening in New Haven,
and they're accompanied
by a manuscript note,
a handwritten note.
The papers are at Beinecke and Yale
because of Mrs. Irwin
Goodenough, Evelyn Goodenough,
whose husband was the
president of the academy,
headquartered three blocks
down Prospect Street.
And the note says,
Stevens gave the sheets to Mrs. Goodenough
who had sat beside the poet and quote,
"studied his stage-fright
"during the earlier parts of the program."
Archives give us extraordinary access
to the humanity of the
people represented there,
and I have to say,
this morning, I'm glad to know
that a future Pulitzer Prize winner
had anxiety even amidst the
friendly audience 70 years ago.
I first read that poem myself
when I was a rising junior
in Yale college during a summer course
on modern American poetry.
And to riff off of Goethe
and the late great Yalie,
Jerry Pelican, what we have
inherited from our parents,
we just possess again in
order to make it our own.
That in many ways is the
work of the university.
And that poem, I have possessed
again and again and again and again
and have made it my own.
If you happen to follow me on Instagram,
you know, ordinary evening
or afternoon or morning,
"In New Haven" is my go-to
verse, even this morning.
Now, today is my 13,076th day
at Yale. (audience laughs)
I've a few ordinary evenings,
mornings, afternoons,
and even late nights here.
I've walked the halls of
this place for 36 years
of its more than 318 years of existence.
I've been a New Havener
for 11% of the days,
since John Davenport first
preached under a huge oak tree,
not far from here.
And I acknowledge, moreover,
that we gather on land,
that the Quinnipiac people
occupied, cultivated,
and stewarded for thousands of years.
In fact every day at home,
I look out over the Quinnipiac meadows
toward Grannis Island,
which was the seasonal home
for the Quinnipiac people.
And as I look out in the
evening or in the morning,
I'm reminded, as the great
scholar John Menta said,
that the Quinnipiac people
were people who lived lives
where thanksgiving was a daily ritual,
a cosmology that has much
to offer us even today.
So I know a little bit about this place
and about its history and maybe that's why
Franz and Julie invited me
to come here this morning
and to share with you.
But first, some housekeeping
before we proceed.
With me, I invite you
to close your laptops,
stow away your mobile phones,
stash your PlayStations,
remove your VR goggles, and disregard
all digital devices for
the duration of this talk.
As a little incentive, you
all should have jotters
that you can make notes on.
And if you're watching this on tape,
no, you don't get a jotter.
There is a benefit for showing up.
So, I ask that we get out of the cloud
and rest comfortably
here on the common ground
of Kroon Hall, on this
campus, in New Haven.
And that we listen together for clarity,
amidst the indistinct
chatter that is so much
our digitally mediated lives,
that we seek as it were,
signal amidst the noise.
I'm joining you in this adventure
of Yale digital unplugged.
I will inflict no
PowerPoint slides on you.
I'm not gonna read from a tiny screen
between me and you.
And I might even make eye contact
as a sign of respect that you are due
in this shared reality
that we make together.
For you are part of this program,
not a mere consumer of data.
As my friend Kae Sun, great
Ghanaian-Canadian musicians
tweeted a few months ago,
"The real conspiracy is to turn everyone
"into a spectator."
Today, let's all be participants,
with our minds open and active.
Now, Franz and Julie actually
invited me as Franz noted,
because we shared a
great adventure together
over the last year and a half or so,
to renew and refresh the
Beinecke Library website,
which I think is the biggest
single, all-in project,
that Yale sites has done to date.
And I trust, not for long
will that record be held,
but we're glad to have been the first.
The project had really
broad participation,
across the Beinecke Library,
working with our colleagues
and the university printer's office.
And I shout them out,
design of a fantastic
jotter and all that we do.
John Gamble, Rebecca
Martz, their colleagues
help us at the Beineke
Library, to keep it real.
And keeping it real was
a big aim of the effort.
Beineke's director E.C. Schroeder,
charged us from the beginning
and encouraged us
throughout to stay to true
to our library's 2027
visions and aspirations,
which include and I quote,
"The call to 'provide
all who enter virtually,
"a level of service,
accessibility, and inspiration,
"on par with that enjoyed on site.
"That our digital be inspired by an on par
"with our actual.'"
We had, as you may know,
in 2015, opened a new site
at 344 Winchester, state of the art home
for Beineke's technical services group.
And then in 2016, the
iconic Bunshaft building
was reopened after complete renovation.
And so in some ways, our work culminating
on February 21st of this year,
was following on with
the digital renovation,
just as we had had physical
renovations before.
The work, the site,
aims to evoke the actual
and to provide clear paths
for the varied constituencies,
and they really are quite varied.
We have 180,000 public visitors on site,
and obviously hundreds
of thousands online.
We have hi-tech folk.
We have low-tech folk.
We have people who are doing research
across all the fields of human endeavor.
We have faculty, we have students.
We have people who see us here
and people who only engage us online.
So it's a very varied audience.
To keep it real, the
new look of the website,
matches, in the digital realm,
the library's design systems for print,
itself, informed by the
physical architecture
of the library that opened in 1963.
On the site, in the footer,
we use Matthew Carter's
marvelous typeface,
as it used throughout the university,
an anchor that ties us to
Yale University overall,
and to the Yale University library system
of which we are a part.
And then, we use, as
you've hopefully seen.
How many people have seen the new website?
Those who didn't raise
their hands are invited to,
but only after we're done.
(audience laughs)
And you've gone off airplane mode
and reopened your laptops.
We use a universe-condensed
family for titles and headers,
and that's a typeface that Rebecca uses
throughout our print to typeface the dates
to the era, mid-century modern era,
of the Beinecke's construction,
so it also again, evokes who we are
and matches with our physical
manifestations in print
and in swag.
And then we use a bright, a cool warm red,
that is inspired by warm printer's red,
and again, a color, highlight color,
that we use across our print
and that you'll see around the building
and in other things that
represent us as we go on the road.
The results of keeping
it real are, we hope,
as it says in the library itself, quote,
"an inspiration to all who enter."
It's a site that seeks, like the library,
to be both grounded and boundless.
Or, to invoke Stevens,
"We keep coming back and
coming back to the real,
"To the hotel, instead of
the hymns that fall upon it
"out of the wind.
"We seek the poem of pure reality,
"untouched by trope or
deviation, straight to the word.
"Straight to the transfixing object,
"to the object at the exactest point
"at which it is itself,
transfixing by being purely
"what it is.
"A view of New Haven say,
through the certain eye.
"The eye made clear of uncertainty,
"with the sight of simple
seeing without reflection.
"We seek nothing beyond reality.
"Within it, everything,
the spirit's alchemicana,
"included the spirit that goes roundabout,
"and through included,
not merely the visible,
"the solid, but the moveable, the moment.
We seek nothing beyond reality.
Within it, everything.
On behalf of the Beinecke library,
I wanna publicly acknowledge and name
the people of Yale ITS,
whose collective labor
made the new website real.
Lisa Sawin, Dana Lipnickas, Franz Hartl,
Jevan Johnson, Taber
Lightfoot, Chao Hang Lu,
Vincent Massaro, Sylvia
Perez, Julie Ramantia,
Mark Saba and Heather White,
and also Rebecca Martz
in the university printer's office.
And I wanna acknowledge the people
of the Beinecke library, who kept it real
and made this real.
In the interest of time,
I'm not gonna name them,
because it is everyone
of the Beineke Library,
who contributed ideas and time and talent
to this site.
There're a 110 or so.
I encourage you to read
their names on the website
after we're done.
By working with the Yale sites team,
we consciously chose to
bring this work home.
It was a wise choice.
Outside vendors and
consultants can be great,
but there is a quantitative
and qualitative benefit
in working with people
who are both colleagues and neighbors.
As a long time citizen of Yale,
I have been delighted to see
how the home-grown capacity
to create websites here has flourished.
It's great now as a consumer and patron,
that the people that I rely on
for digital infrastructure
and design are nearby,
and that frankly they're people I run into
at the farmer's market in Wooster Square
and other places around town.
Happily gone are the days
of back and forth email,
to set up a conference call a week out,
to schedule an onsite meeting a month out.
An instead, we have excellent assistance,
right next door, from real
people we really know.
And bringing the work back
home also made a difference
in the results you see,
because all of the people
I named know the reality
and were informed, really informed,
by the reality of the library.
All of our meetings happened on site,
in the library, and there's
something in the air
of the place.
The people who made this
site walked the walk
and breathed the air time
after time after time.
And I have to say, to shout out Dana,
and along with my colleagues,
I was delighted, not
only by the time we spent
in a room together, but that she often,
with her laptop after meetings,
had concluded, stuck
around the courtyard level
and did her own work
there, remotely as it were,
but actually not remotely.
And I don't think that there's
a precise quantitative
measure that we could apply
to what that ministry of presence meant,
but I am confident the
results speak for themselves
of being there, actually,
truly being there.
For you see, there is a virtue,
with engaging reality,
that surpasses the delights
of virtual reality.
Now the work we did together resulted
in a wonderful website
that does work well.
Some here, and part of me, are quants,
and the quants will be happy to know
that we have solid data so
far to prove that it works.
In the first 100 days,
which would be February 21 to May 31st,
the number of unique views of the homepage
grew 5%.
And that's good.
We obsess a bit about the homepage
because in our design thinking,
we really prioritized and privileged
those who don't know us.
And so we really sweated
that in particular.
So increased traffic is good.
You don't want it going
in the other direction,
that's for sure.
But here's the better news.
Average time on the
homepage is down by 33%,
while the bounce rate is down by 32%.
Long story short, not only
are more people coming,
more people are more
quickly finding ways to go
and going there, rather
than if we again used
the real building, just going
through the revolving door
for a while and popping back out,
with never making it into the library.
So these quantitative measures
area really great news.
And the trend in the first 100
plus days has been very good.
We also have qualitative testimony,
in person and online.
My favorite comes from our
colleague Brita Belli OPAC,
who had the powerful
simple reaction on Twitter,
the fire emoji.
(audience laughs)
It's good, if your design
merits the fire emoji.
And I'm even thinking that I may
use that as the sum total in
the year-end results column
of my managing at Yale
performance process review.
(audience laughs)
So the reality is this,
more people are finding
their way more quickly
and more often to what really matters,
the collection, the
programs, the exhibitions,
the people, the research, the scholarship,
of the library.
And in communications,
that's what really matters,
that's what really counts.
We need to measure success,
not only in the metrics
that Google gives us,
and that social media analytics provide,
but the measure, sometimes
quite intangible, but real,
is how well we serve to
welcome students and faculty
and researchers and public
visitors to the place,
so that they can engage,
confront, and build
on the rich record of human experience
and cultural achievement that we steward.
So a clearer, faster website means
we can better serve people
as they engage the past,
in the present, for the future.
Perhaps our montra is
less time on website for
more time on real site.
A clearer, faster website
is a means towards the end
of more people lingering,
wandering, exploring,
and looking for themselves
in the actual library.
Some of you may now, I'm a Kentuckian.
And Kentuckian's are always happy
when other Kentuckian's are cited.
So I was delighted to hear words
of Hunter S. Thompson
yesterday, you will recall them.
"Faster faster, until the thrill of speed
"overcomes the fear of death!"
Now if you know brother
Hunter in his life,
he did know a little bit about speed,
both the motorcycle variety
and the amphetamine variety.
(audience laughs)
And his life and living and it's ending
brings to mind another great saying,
not of Kentucky but of
the world, "Speed kills."
So, this Kentuckian's
mantra might rather be,
"Faster, faster, until you
get where you can slow down,
"and think and engage with reality."
For you see, we seek
nothing beyond reality.
Within it, everything.
And so for the Beinecke library,
a faster, better website
means more people might come
to see the real first printing
of the U.S. Declaration of Independence,
which will be on view again soon,
June 28th through July 11th.
It is the first document of the nation,
printed on July 4, 1776,
one of 26 copies surviving,
of about 200.
Printed in Philadelphia
on that day, July 4, 1776,
and immediately sent out on
horseback and stagecoach,
throughout the states of the new nation.
It is the original viral
media of the nation.
And to see that document is to
find nothing beyond reality,
and within it, everything.
When it was on view last year,
I happened upon a family who was visiting
from Toledo, Ohio, who had come to see
the Declaration of Independence on view.
The parents were standing
on either side of the case
reading it aloud, the full
declaration to each other
and to their two kids.
One declared, as she read,
"These words don't seem so old.
"They seem very relevant right now."
Indeed, they are at once,
timeless and timely.
And that is a reality
that is most accessible
in the present of the real thing.
The papers in the Beinecke Library
and special collections
elsewhere on campus
and around the world are not dead trees.
They are living testimony.
They are actual evidence of who we were,
who we are, and who we might be.
And so a faster, better
website means more people
might come to see the first printing
of Frederick Douglass'
oration, given on July 5, 1852,
to the Rochester Ladies'
Anti-slavery Society.
That is where Mr. Douglass asks,
"What to the American
slaves your Fourth of July?"
And Mr. Douglass provided the answer
from the harsh reality he knew.
Mr. Douglass wrote, said, and is printed,
"I answer a day that reveals to him more
"than all the other days of the year,
"the gross injustice
and cruelty to which he
"is the constant victim.
"To him, your celebration is a sham;
"Your boasted liberty, an unholy license;
"Your national greatness, swelling vanity;
"Your sounds of rejoicing
are empty and heartless;
"Your denunciations of tyrants,
brass-fronted impudence;
"Your shouts of liberty and
equality hollow mockery:
"Your prayers and hymns;
"Your sermons and thanksgiving;
"with all your religious
parade and solemnity
"are, to Him, mere bombast,
fraud and deception, impiety,
"and hypocrisy, a thin
veil to cover up crimes
"which would disgrace
a nation of savages."
Words that echo today.
This is the 400th anniversary,
of when a ship set sail
with enslaved Africans,
headed to Jamestown.
These are words that
are timely and timeless.
For you see friends,
there is a virtue in confronting reality.
Perhaps even more so,
when that reality itself,
is far from virtuous.
The reality accessible in repositories
like the Beinecke Library,
and peers across campus,
around that nation
and across the world,
have the virtue of
encouraging us to remember.
And they remind us that our nation's deeds
do not always match its words.
And so a faster, better website,
means that more people might encounter
the first printing of the
Women's Rights Convention
at Seneca Falls, July 19th, 20th, 1848.
A report printed at the North Star Press,
Frederick Douglass' press,
and a report that includes
a declaration of sentiments,
which I think needs to
be much better known
as a document of the nation.
171 years ago, the convention declared,
"We hold these truths to be self-evident
"that all men and women are
created equal," in 1848.
For words of the world
are the life of the world.
And a faster, better website
means more people might engage more deeply
with the living legacy of Langston Hughes,
whose literary archives live in 672 boxes
at the heart of our campus.
They might remember his words,
words that inspired Lorraine Hansberry
and Martin Luther King Jr.,
words that echo today.
What happens to a dream deferred?
And a faster, better
website means more people
might be inspired by how Hughes reckoned
with his reality,
how he confronted the
past and examined it,
and still concluded with an
eye to the future as he said,
"Oh yes, I say it plain.
"American never was America to me,
"and yet I swear this oath.
"America will be."
And so a faster, better
website makes it possible
to enable countless, real-time encounters
in the exhibition hall,
in the reading room, in the classrooms,
as well as proxy-encounters
on the digital library.
That oft impalpable
impact is in many ways,
what counts the most.
As the brilliant Elizabeth
Alexander wrote in 2016,
when the National Museum
of African American History
and Culture opened, and I quote,
"Historians and curators are heroes.
"The digging, the trench
work and smoothing,
"the conjuration it
takes to piece together
"filament by filament, a history,
"and then to present it
so that we understand
"and experience it as a living process,
"is nothing short of wizardry."
"History," Elizabeth wrote,
"is not a triumphal
march to the finish line.
"History is not all upturn
faces, nor ascendant.
"History is made up of struggle,
contradiction, resistance."
Professor Alexander keeps
it real, and so must we.
Keeping it real also
means not being distracted
by the brightest, shiniest objects,
and not diluted by the disruption machine.
Yale alumna Jill Lepore got right
what the gospel of innovation gets wrong
in her 2014 New Yorker piece, and I quote,
"Disruptive innovation
doesn't explain change.
"It's not a law of nature.
"It's an artifact of history,
an idea forged in time.
"It's the manufacturer of a moment
"of upsetting and edgy uncertainty.
"Transfixed by change,
it's blind to continuity.
"It makes a very poor profit."
Professor Lepore keeps
it real, so must we.
Spoiler alert!
The machines will not
save us by themselves.
And the evidence is all around us to see.
Valerie Strauss headlined
in the Washington Post,
couple of weeks ago,
"New report on virtual
education: As it turns out,
it is to good to be true."
As Brett Stevens opined
in the Times on May 3,
"Over the past several
years, we've learned a lot
"about the unintended
consequences of social media.
"Platforms intended to
bring us closer together,
"make us angry and more isolated.
"Platforms aimed and democratizing
"speech-empowered demagogues,
"Platforms celebrating
community violate our privacy
"in ways we scarcely realize
and serve as conduits
"for deceptions, hiding in plain sight."
Max Boot, a couple of weeks
ago in the Post asked,
"Are we becoming too stupid
to govern ourselves?"
And observed, "it's true that the internet
"has put a lot of information online,
"but like diners passing
up a healthy salad
"for an artery-clogging cheeseburger,
"many information consumers are instead,
"digesting junk news."
And just the other day,
M.R. O'Connor reported
on a new study.
She was writing, M.R. was
writing in The Washington Post
on June 5.
The headline was, "Ditch the
GPS, it's ruining your brain."
"When people use tools," the story says,
"such as GPS, they tend to
engage less with navigation.
"Therefore, brain area
responsible for navigation
"is less used.
"And consequently, their brain
areas involved in navigation
"tend to shrink."
Little bit scary.
So, at at time when machines
are gaining autonomy,
are we doing enough to protect
and promote human liberty?
In a time of deep fakes
and information overload,
are we doing enough to keep it real?
We surely can use quantum science,
but we also must have quality humanities,
if we are to have quality
of life as humans.
Libraries, museums, and universities stand
as essential arsenals for
liberty and democracy.
They house the living
materials necessary to confront
what Gore Vidal called, "The
United States of Amnesia,
"where we learn nothing
because we remember nothing."
Libraries, museums, and
universities invite us
to be alive in the world, to
call forth active citizens,
rather than passive spectators.
Libraries, museums, and
universities should keep it real.
In an ethos, in a era when the
ethos of creative destruction
runs amuck in the markets,
we should be in words
of President Salovey,
"a place of creative construction,
"a place of both innovation and tradition.
"A place where we draw form the past,
"in the present, to build the future."
President Salovey said
Yale embraces quote,
"creative construction,
"not orthodox adherence to the past,
"nor the pursuit of innovation,
"merely for its own sake,
but a dynamic tradition.
"We don't just seek to make new things.
"We seek to make things better."
Now as we collectively aim
to make both better things
and to make things better,
let me offer some
tangible, practical ideas
applicable, perhaps to workplace culture.
First, and maybe second and last,
get out more often.
Like Dana, practice a
ministry of presence.
Let's not all be stuck in
our cubicles or offices
or hotel space, wherever we are routinely,
where we do the work.
Use Zoom Rooms for sure,
but also make real room in your schedule,
to wander, to explore, to look closely
at this extraordinary place to acknowledge
what it is, its opportunities,
its challenges, its history.
For it is in that, that we
can construct the future.
If you're in ITS, as many are here,
communications like me,
service providers to
departments and schools,
be like the Yale site's team was with us
at the Beinecke.
Really get to know the place.
Be in it, be present.
Spend real time on site,
as we all create things
to live online.
Go to the Grove Street Cemetery.
Go to the art gallery.
Go to the Center for British Art.
Go to the New Haven Museum.
Give yourself the time.
It will pay off in many ways.
And remember words of the world
are the life of the world.
In the beginning was the word,
a book that's on permanent view
at the Beinecke Library says,
"Writing matters.
"Writing really matters in
this place and for our world."
And, since it's summer season,
some potential summer reading,
I have never gone wrong with Maria Popova,
and "Brain Pickings."
If you don't know it, read it.
And read a book or two or three.
We should not be the kind of people,
who accept Bill Barr's blended reality.
Read the actual Mueller Report.
Read my dear friend Casey Gerald's,
"There Will Be No Miracles Here,"
a powerful memoir by
a recent alum of Yale,
who definitely keeps it real.
And/or read John Menta's history
of the Quinnipiac people,
on who's land we stand.
Acknowledge not only that history,
but get to know that history.
When you visit the Grove Street Cemetery,
pay your respects at
the life, at the grave
of William Grimes, who in 1825
wrote the first, first-person narrative
and published it himself of a person
who escaped enslavement
and lived in this town,
and is buried in our cemetery.
At the Beinecke Library,
we have the first printing.
His ancestors have ensured
that it remains in print.
A powerful, powerful document.
And in this 400th
anniversary of the arrival
of the first enslaved people on the shores
of what is now our country,
read Ibram Kendi's extraordinary book,
"Stamped From The Beginning,"
to understand the reality on the ground
and the ideas that shaped this nation
and that we live with today.
Ibram Kendi does extraordinary
historic and archival work
and again shows that the
documents and the history
are not dead.
It is still amongst us now.
So, on this ordinary morning in New Haven,
I encourage you to stay for
the rest of the conference,
but get out more often (audience laughs).
On this ordinary morning in New Haven,
I think we all know we live
in extraordinary times.
And we need to acknowledge
that we live in times
of existential challenge,
to what this nation is,
to what this world is.
And as, on this ordinary
morning in New Haven,
we acknowledge that we live
in extraordinary times,
I encourage you, equip yourselves well.
The world requires the
reality-based community
now more than ever.
I shall neither insult your intelligence
nor assault your conscience.
You know what to do.
Seek nothing beyond reality,
within it, everything.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
(light gentle music)